Marjorie Desjardins je suis réalisatrice
de documentaire photographe et aussi
chef opératrice mon premier documentaire
s'appelle femme Jean filigran c'est avec
ma grand-mère et Benoît de Goult et en
fait c'est un portrait croisé entre les
deux femmes
ma grand-mère ayant plutôt subi sa vie
de femmes et Benoît Groodt étant devenu
féministe et reconnu plutôt verset 40
ans et ont pris les armes des mots pour
pour témoigner
aujourd'hui pour présenter des extraits
de mes films qui traitent du rapport des
femmes à leur corps et de l'évolution
des femmes dans la société
et nous sommes semblait très important
dans un endroit tel qu'une faculté de
droits de transmettre ce que j'ai pu
apprendre sur pas mal d'années ou dans
mes rencontres et faire du documentaire
c'est pouvoir s'asseoir à la table du
diable c'est à dire aborder tous les
sujets et puis faire un petit peu bouger
les curseurs de ce qu'ils peuvent ou
aura été
mais on dire mes illusions
mes prérequis mon éducation bousculer
mon ethnocentrisme
en tant que femme je suis libre et je ne
suis en grandissant vers la vingtaine où
je me suis dit mais en fait j'ai des
j'ai des limites parce que je suis fan
c'est quoi c'est connerie et c'est en
discutant avec ma grand-mère de tout ce
qu'elle avait vu vivre que je me suis
dit voilà lâcher sur certaines choses et
en fait c'était les autres qui me
rappelaient que j'étais femme comme si
être femme
m'empêchait ce qui était quelque chose
pour moi de totalement inconcevable
puisque je pouvais partir avec mon sac à
dos et ma caméra faire des documentaires
un peu partout dans le monde comme le
disait Benoît de Goult dit à la fin de
mon film c'est que c'est aux hommes de
faire un effort maintenant si on veut
une égalité dans les droits on les a
mais on va dire le salaire etc c'est à
eux de faire des efforts et de
rétrocéder du terrain c'est difficile
[Musique]